[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
7,8 le débat reprendre confiance en soi
grâce à l'improvisation c'est ce que
propose plusieurs compagnies de théâtre
dans des ateliers destinés aux jeunes et
aux adultes genre à part entière dans le
théâtre contemporain l'improvisation est
un passage presqu'obligé pour les
artistes qui souhaitent se lancer dans
le stand-up et pour nous autres amateurs
la pratique du théâtre d'improvisation
pourrait nous aider dans notre rapport
aux autres nous avons invité sur ce
plateau deux professionnels du théâtre
pour en parler
norel yakine louise vous êtes
responsable de l'improvisation de la
compagnie déclic théâtre et nathalie
henrion vous êtes comédiennes de la
compagnie in ucao davouze est en
résidence à la ferme bel ébat de
guyancourt et vous intervenez aussi dans
des ateliers pour adultes bonsoir à tous
les deux construits nous rayer qui ne
vous enseignez l'improvisation à des
adolescents un certain jamel debbouze
s'est formé chez vous qu'est ce qui
plaît dans l'impro aux ados qu'est ce
qui plaît dans l'impro aux ados et je
pense que ce qui plaît c'est c'est
d'abord le rapport de pouvoir se
confronter
dans un jeu puisque nous ce qu'on
propose c'est avant tout des matchs
d'improvisation dans un premier temps et
du coup ce qui valait ce qu'ils valent
et les attirer ce qui va les amener au
jeu c'est l'idée de pouvoir entre
guillemets être meilleur que l'autre
donc ça c'est vraiment voilà la partie
sport qui est qui qui qui est très
compétition la partie compétition est
forcément qui est forcément attirante
parce que du coup elle et met en valeur
c'est le terme à les estimer auprès du
public vis-à-vis d'une autre équipe
c'est vrai mais en tout cas estimé la
valeur d'une équipe ou d'un joueur et
après quand ils y sont
bah ce qui leur fait rester surtout
c'est le plaisir qui trouve à faire du
théâtre avant tout et
et ça ça je pense que c'est ce qui fait
que ça dure
nathalie orient du côté des adultes je
pense pas que ce soit l'aspect
compétition qu'on recherche vous ce goût
avec lesquels vous travaillez dans vos
ateliers ils viennent pourquoi c'est
pour créer du lien fait vraiment du lien
social
j'ai envie de dire amicale parce que
nous on a deux heures hebdomadaires
hebdomadaire pendant pour monter un
spectacle mais ça suffit pas parce qu'il
faut faire des des italiennes ce qu'on
appelle juste le texte avant de faire
une mise en place donc nous avons tous
et c'est du lien c'est
et ça rassemble j'ai envie de dire à la
fois des gens qui sont en activité
d'autres qui le sont pas mon
momentanément ou voilà qu'une petite
comme ça absence et qui vont du coup se
remettre par ce lien social parce qu'on
parle parce qu'on dit tiens la honte
elle tellement cherche telle ou telle
personne on va se remettre dans une vie
active vraiment sociale et et c'est ça
que j'aime beaucoup en fait et on a
aussi des gens passionnés qui sont à la
retraite et c'est vraiment ce qui gêne
pour leur plaisir c'est un loisir
aurélien quine du côté des ados skis et
ce besoin de lien social aussi de
s'amuser ensemble bien sûr s'amuser
ensemble partager raconter des histoires
ensemble mettre en commun aussi
leur culture parce que finalement c'est
un espace improvisation et un peu
matières premières quand on est comme
une improvisation des matières premières
de ce que les histoires vous raconter et
c'est vrai que les adolescents pour le
coup ils ont une culture très similaires
les uns vis-à-vis des autres mais en
même temps ils sont chargés de leur
histoire familiale leur histoire
personnelle de voilà de leur histoire de
coeur ou ceci ou cela et un moment donné
ce genre de choses et ben voilà ça vient
se retranscrire dans des émotions qui
vont partager avec l'autre et qu'ils
vont mettre en commun en tout cas et
c'est marrant parce que on parle souvent
de deux des différences des uns et des
autres voilà comment il un comme l autre
mais en tout cas en improvisation c'est
vrai que ce qui sauve souvent le
comédien d'improvisation c'est de mettre
en commun ce qui ce qu'il peut apporter
dans ces histoires et adoucit les
différents ça laisse aller mais sur un
autre plan pour faire du théâtre faux
comment dire se lier d'amitié avec des
choses une petite histoire un enjeu et
donc il faut il faut être sûr en fait
j'ai envie de dire sur le même niveau
faut faire partie de la même famille
d'abord on parle de troupes ou de
compagnie et donc ont créé cette idée de
troupes de très fraternelle en fait
parce qu'on a besoin de compter les uns
sur les autres et même physiquement
parce que nous on est amené à faire
déporter à faire des choses physiques on
s'engage faut avoir confiance dans la
camarade en l'autre la confiance est
quelque chose d'assez essentiel et puis
quand on a généré la confiance c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qui qui ne
se défait plus quoi c'est à dire que un
ami comédien un ami comédien on le
retrouve juste après le plateau on va le
retrouver tout au long de sa vie parce
qu'on va faire un parcours de comédien
avec lui proches loin selon les parcours
des uns et des autres mais en tout cas
on sait que c'est les personnes avec
lesquelles qui vont compter le plus pour
nous dans notre équipe junior de trappes
là qui est championne du monde c'est
quelque chose de très flagrant par
exemple il ya eu une première génération
avec sophia aram
arnaud joyet manuel urban et ce sont des
gens qui travaillaient encore ensemble
je travaille encore avec les gens de ma
génération et puis et puis d'autres
mathieu longatte leur hyper et où
d'autres travaillent encore en vie puis
mort sont encore une autre troupe
d'improvisation qui travaillent encore
ensemble
c'est vrai que générationnel mans il ya
des choses qui se font et qui est qui
font qu'il ya du vrai lien est
indéfectible d'accord alors on parle
souvent de l'improvisation de ces
vertueux pour la confiance en soi qu
est-ce que pourquoi ça agi parce que si
on s'imagine un peu timide
on se dit qu'on va pas se jeter sur
scène comme ça devant les autres qu'est
ce qui fait que ça marche que ça nous
aide
alors la timidité ça se soigne pas de la
timidité mais sans fait des comédiens
sensible je pense à gérard philipe ou
des acteurs qui ont une grande timidité
mais une fois qu'ils sont sur le plateau
c'est comme s'ils sont dans une grande
boîte noire où ils sont encore plus
naturel encore plus vivant encore plus
de liberté que quand on est dans sa
petite chambre à jouer avec eux c'est
toutes ces choses et ces histoires et
moi j'avais la timidité c'est on
n'oublie jamais mais c'est très
révélateur sur sur certains acteurs y en
a plein qui sont très in the wind et il
se transforme un peu sur ces analyses
viennent quelqu'un dont ils ont blessé
timidité ils ont payé leur imerisia
mêmes libertés qui arrive tout de suite
où ils vont jouer du coup avec tous les
objets les copains les camarades et ça
devient jubilatoire mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut s'oublier et ça vous à même
de travailler des adultes qui sont très
hésitants au début qu'est ce que vous
leur dites pour les pousser un petit peu
j'ai envie de dire c'est le fait d'être
de faire plaindre en fin d'exercice
ensemble voilà de mémorisation vous avez
aussi dit oui c'est à dire que nous
avons bien souvent là en plus dans leur
donne leur jeune âge dans leur parcours
souvent les parents ou les professeurs
désinscrivent à l'improvisation en
disant voilà celui-là est timide
celui-là et caïds
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire pour lui
mais en vrai
ce qui est intéressant avec
l'improvisation c'est que ça permet la
même ligne de départ en tout cas pour
l'ensemble des participants à un atelier
et il se retrouva à pas être confronté
ni à la lecture ni à l'apprentissage
ça permet de découvrir le théâtre de la
manière d'une manière assez brutale en
fait on peut se confondre très
rapidement un public est là en
l'occurrence pour des personnes
ben timide très rapidement à se dire oui
à être obligés de construire l'histoire
très rapidement elles sont obligées
d'aller au delà de ce défaut qui est que
qu'elle porte
parce que finalement en faisant danser
puis en improvisation le public et enfin
dans la manière on le pratique nous
public est là on joue en improvisant
donc c'est mais en est que ce soit en
atelier ou le résultat final on est
confronté à la même chose donc on est
obligé de passer ce cap est forcément
ben ça ça a du bon parce que finalement
effectivement on gomme on en ressort
fier d'avoir eu la barrière
vous avez travaillé n'était en rien avec
des demandeurs d'emploi des gens qui
étaient dans des situations un petit peu
justement où la confiance en soi est
très nécessaire racontez nous un peu
comment comment ils s'en sont sortis
déjà avec des jeux théâtraux qu'on fait
très simple en fait qu' on est toujours
obligé d'être à l'écouté de l'autre on
n'a pas de baguette magique
en tout cas ils ont tous retrouvé
un emploi d'accord vous avez vous avez
accueilli combien de participants à cet
atelier alors il y en avait huit en fait
dont certains ont retrouvé un emploi
dans la région ou ailleurs mais en fait
ils ont des jeunes et des moins jeunes
des personnes comme en 50 ans et c'est
voilà quelques années encore d'activités
pour certaines ils ont tous retrouvé un
emploi dont on n'a pas de baguette
magique mais en tout cas
qu'est ce que vous avez fait ce que vous
les avez je sais pas imaginer devant un
entretien d'embauché exactement l
inverse plein d'exercices comme ça de
rédaction aussi ce que nous c'est vrai
qu'on passe beaucoup par le verbe
formule est vraiment ce qu'on veut et où
on veut où on va pourquoi on y va donc
ça on l'a fait aussi par l'écriture
et donc voilà d'être toujours très
concret dans tout ce qu'on me propose et
ses personnages ou les retrouve aussi
sur l'atelier adultes de guyancourt
entre autres donc ils sont restés avec
vous ici ils vont me conduit va la vie
continue ils ont un emploi maintenant
qui leur permettent de devenir
régulièrement d'accord au niveau des
adolescents c'est vrai qu'on ce qu'on se
dit que l'école est pas forcément un
milieu mon père excentrique on peut
s'affirmer c'est plutôt un milieu qui
uniformise est ce que justement ça leur
perdre c'est un espace d'expression
finalement l'impro ça leur permet de
c'est en fait c'est un milieu où on peut
être excentrique en fait mais c'est à
nos risques et périls
voilà j'ai envie de dire il y en a qui
disent ils dans le monde des adultes
vide on a envie de rendre les choses un
peu conforme et c'est vrai que nous
avoir la chance de pouvoir intervenir
dans les collèges depuis depuis près de
vingt ans maintenant c'est peut-être
l'un des rares espaces d'expression où
la parole elle est cadré parce qu'il ya
un arbitre des règles on ne peut pas
faire ce qu'on veut non plus
en tout cas où la parole est libre on
peut parler de ce qu'on veut on peut
aborder les choses la manière dont le
but est alors peut-être un petit peu en
dessin pas beaucoup en musique mais
c'est vrai que les espaces d'expression
dans les établissements scolaires ici je
dis pas qu'il n'existe pas je dis juste
que
à la volée comme ça c'est difficile de
les compter il n'y a pas d'établissement
scolaire pourvu d'un théâtre par exemple
ou d'un auditorium de musique ils sont
rares en tout cas et c'est vrai que
c'est le genre d'équipement qui peuvent
manquer pour justement pour le bien-être
parce que je pense que c'est assez
essentiel de pouvoir s'exprimer dans nos
intérêts pour pour eux il faut pour
pouvoir s'exprimer il faut justement
créer du lien les uns entre les autres
qui ait pas d'affrontement entre
montréal et redéfinit les gars okoumé
mais voilà c'est ça qu'il faut vraiment
créer des choses sympathiques à faire
pour qu'ils aient envie d'être ensemble
et construire quelque chose quoi ça
c'est le rôle du professeur de terre
peut-être qui les accompagnent voilà je
reviens à ce lien social qui était
important dans ce livre ait envie de
mener des aventures quoi d'accord
qu'est-ce que vous recommander aux gens
qui ont envie d'essayer mais qui évite
faut pas hésiter infos-eau tcc
on a tous des choses à raconter en fait
c'est ça qui est assez incroyable j'ai
tout s'est extrêmement riche alors des
fois on se dit mais qu'est ce que je
vais dire quand je peux improviser
qu'est ce que je vais dire bah déjà
qu'est ce que je vais dire c'est un
super point de départ en vérité mais il
faut juste se mettre au milieu d'une
salle est prêt à l'exprimer face à deux
trois personnes au départ pour pouvoir
aller avec ce que je leur dis toujours
c'est que le théâtre c'est de la pensée
avant tout c'est à dire c'est une idée
c'est à dire que bien souvent le théâtre
c'est quand même des notions de conflit
ou un engagement amoureux et donc il ya
toujours la pensée les mots qui vont
avec
comment comment le raconte et ça ils en
sont ils en sont fiers de s'approprier
aussi des paroles qui ne sont pas les
leurs rôles et les lots pour conclure
chaque et juste pour finir sur cette
idée la sq en plus en improvisation
n'est pas tout seul c'est à dire qu'on
s'appuie énormément sur l'autre donc
parle du lien on est obligé de se dire
oui si on dit pas oui en improvisation
on atténue une histoire on l'a conclue
très très vite alors que le wii permet
d'aller de l'avant et surtout il permet
d'accepter les propositions de l'autre
et de rebondir sur les propositions de
doute là je suis déjà dans un truc très
technique mais mais en l'occurrence
c'est l'une des règles essentielles pour
pouvoir avancer et pour ceux qui
hésitent effectivement faut surtout
qu'ils sachent qu'ils sont pas tout
seuls à être sur scène et que et qu'il
ne vend que enrichir sans interlocuteur
qui parle un dernier match aller que ses
idées en fait quand on est tout petit
déjà dans sa chambre on allait les lego
les mobiles et tout ce qu'on veut donc
se raconter des histoires il faut
simplement le garder quand on grandit et
finalement c'est en fait ça depuis qu'on
est tout petit il faut bougies se
remettre dans nos habits d'enfants
ok merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé ainsi la sellerie mission et
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau 7 8 le débat très bonne fin
de soirée
au revoir
[Musique]